[Music]
spider-man no way home takes everything
you know about spider-man films and puts
it on a blender until what emerges is a
completely new beginning thanks to a
botched large-scale identity unlearning
spell by dr strange everyone in the
multiverse who's aware of peter parker's
connection to spider-man starts making
their way to the mcu earth while this
means tom holland's peter gets to meet
his alternate universe counterparts toby
maguire's peter and andrew garfield's
peter it also means that they have to
join forces to subdue no less than five
of the biggest villains in the history
of spider-man movies green goblin doctor
octopus sandman lizard and electro the
scale of no way home is downright
astounding and apart from telling a
story of its own it's not afraid to
explore deep cuts from the maguire and
garfield era either however some fans
might have wondered why the movie
doesn't go all in and include a sixth
villain as well this would after all
complete the sinister six a classic
super team that consists of villains
with a grudge against spider-man the
more you think about the absence of a
sixth antagonist the stranger it is
really so why didn't spider-man no way
home introduced the sinister six there
are many possible reasons why spider-man
no way home doesn't go full sinister six
for one the movie seems to adhere to a
pretty strict rule of one major villain
per pre-tom holland spidey movie and
since there's a grand total of five such
films that's pretty much it besides
there technically is a sixth villain in
the movie venom only it's the tom hardy
incarnation who only learned of
spider-man's existence in the
post-credits scene of venom let there be
carnage he continues his peripheral mcu
existence in the no way home stinger
which reveals he got stuck getting drunk
in a faraway destination and couldn't be
bothered to make his way to new york
before he's drawn back to his own
reality if you refuse to accept hardy's
brief cameo appearance as the missing
piece of the sinister six there are
several notable movie villains who are
missing from no way home but there are
reasons why they don't show up in the
movie paul giamatti had already noted
that his rhino won't appear in no way
home and the dame dihan and james franco
versions of green goblin would likely
have been confusing in a movie that so
prominently features the willem dafoe
version of the character likewise tom
hardy's venom pretty much means that the
topher grace version would have been the
odd man out interesting as it might have
been to revisit that incarnation of the
character this leaves the mcu
spider-man's own rogues gallery of which
mysterio is supposedly dead and michael
keaton is heavily rumored to reprise his
role as vulture in the upcoming morbius
which would make his appearance here
redundant if you want to get technical
about it spider-man no way home doesn't
really feature even five true super
villains at the same time sure electro
and lizard are consistently villainous
and at best biding their time to resume
their wicked ways however the rest of
the film's baddies change their
allegiances over the course of the movie
sandman starts out as something of an
ally to spider-man only becoming
antagonistic later down the line otto
octavius and norman osborne are both
good dudes when not possessed by their
villainous shackles and it just so
happens that the former is freed from
the mind control of his ai tentacles
around the same time the latter's
villainous goblin persona takes over
thanks to these various good and evil
turns the group only has the makings of
a sinister three or four at any given
time further muddying the waters is the
fact that the whole plot basically
happens because of spider-man far from
home villain mysterio and j jonah
jameson who reveals spider-man's
identity to the world and who most
certainly counts as the webslinger's
opponent in fact even doctor strange
himself acts as spidey's antagonist at
one point as such you could argue that
despite its vast wealth of villainy no
way home isn't particularly interested
in putting a sinister six together
besides it's always possible that by not
giving fans a full iteration of the
villain team no way home ensures the
possibility of a more formal sinister
six somewhere in poor peter parker's
future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spider-man no way home are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one